but if one of your kids turned out to be
gay and wanted to get married would you
be tough on Tough Enough that to say so
when it is the Old Testament when it's
the Torah yes when it's a Jew in front
of you you scumbag Pier Morgan
islamophobic douchebag it's okay I
understand you know we know you have
religious views and blah blah blah blah
blah blah so understanding but when it's
a
Muslim do you want to speak with
confidence like these amazing
personalities every single one of these
amazing speakers have taken the same
program with brother Muhammad Arad
Muhammad Arad has helped develop all of
us it's extremely beneficial to do this
course definitely recommend this
course to access the free lifechanging
training
now brothers and sisters and dear
friends Allah subhana says in the Quran
I'll get straight into it do not take
the people of the book as intimate
friends CU they are friends to one
another brothers and sisters when Allah
subhana wa T talks we don't take it
seriously until you live and see it it
for yourself now does that mean myself I
don't have friends that are Jews and
Christians or atheist for that matter of
course I do but Allah says do not take
the most intimate friends why because we
know in the Battle of bad there were
people who were fighting their family
members Brothers uncles husbands on the
other side that's why we say blood is
thicker than water but IM is thicker
than blood and like Allah subh said to
Alam when Alam said I thought he was
going to save my family when his son
drowned and Allah subh rebuked Alam and
said your the Believers are your family
make that very categorically clear look
at this video we're going to react to
now of Ben Shapiro the American
journalist the coward weasel who gulped
when he saw hijabs presence yes he
craped and shut himself yes that's what
he is a piece of crap now watch how
Piers Morgan treats Ben Shapiro Pi
Morgan this flipping islamophobic bigot
by the way Pi Morgan I've got surprise
for you it's going to be unexpected one
a legal one a peaceful one don't worry
about that we'll come to that later but
watch how he speaks to Ben shapir when
it comes to issue of homosexuality let's
see it for ourself in what would you do
if one of your K they're all very young
you have no idea but if one of your kids
turned out to be gay and wanted to get
married would you be tough on Tough
Enough that to say you can't do that I
mean I would oppose that from so
religion so again marriage exists a yeah
religious so so marriage exists in a
couple of different iterations one is
religious marriage which is kind of what
I care about and then there is
governmental sanctioned marriage which
is a public policy question when it
comes to religious marriage no I I'm not
in favor of My Religion sanctifying
same-sex couples specifically because
again my religion propagates the idea
that man woman and child is the model
for families let's take a break I want
to come back and talk to you about what
the big question so there you go guys
look at attitude you know of course I
understand your religion of course I
understand your religion is it yeah why
why do you why do you scrutinize him why
do you ask him does he want the um the
uh the um the the law of talmud yes of
the Torah to be applied in in uh in the
UK ask him ask him does he condemn that
ask him yes why don't you ask him there
was a rabbi who went on a stabbing spree
in Israel cuz there was a lgbqt March
happening yeah so why doesn't he treat
him like that but look how he treats
Abdul Wahid yeah look at the watch the
watch the video how he asks him just to
clarify what is your view of
homosexuality I believe homosexuality is
a sin don't sin wrong so when gay people
come to your your practice do you treat
them oh of course why because I treat
all my patients with kindness and
without you tell them you think what
they do is a sin what an absurd thing to
say why why wouldn't you be say that why
would I say that because they don't come
why don't you try going back to your
surgery tomorrow come to me why don't
you go to surgery tomorrow say before we
go any further to your patience I want
you to know what I think I think that I
agree with the guy who said the this
country is full of LGBT filth feminist
filth I don't think Hamas are a terror
group I don't think what they did in
October the 7 was a terror attack and by
the way do you want me now to treat you
do you want do you understand what I
don't understand any of that
professional Integrity is you understand
you think that's professional Integrity
no I think professional Integrity is
treating the people I treat with respect
and with kindness how do I so guys do
you see that disparity do you see the
double stand hypocrisy look at his
attitude and his tone and understanding
of course it's your religion so when it
is the Old Testament when it's the Torah
yes when it's a Jew in front of you you
scumbag Pier Morgan
islamophobic douchebag it's okay
understand you know we know you have
religious views and blah blah blah blah
blah blah so understanding but when it's
a Muslim this is how you know this guy
is an flipping islamophobe a closet
islamophobe a bigot deep down that's why
he cannot condemn the idea that's why he
cannot condemn Israel he cannot because
he knows where his Lo his lies yes for
him to see if any Muslim Army was to do
what IDF is doing to Any Nation there
would be Absol I tell you something
there would be Chaos on the streets we
as Muslims will be probably getting
attacked on the streets Left Right
Center okay there would be probably a
civil war but it's okay it's the
muslim's blood no problem Allah is the
best of planers
Islam we want Sharia in the UK we want
Sharia for everybody do you even know
what Sharia means huh do you even know
what Sharia means yeah you need sh UK is
dying for Shar you are making your
elderly die at home alone you flipping
selfish individuals you go on holidays
and put them in Care Homes while they
are dying they are dying they looked
after you and chained your nappies and
looked after you when you was a baby and
you reached this age on materialism and
the Western propaganda has consumed you
so much that you are more concerned
going to iifa for a holiday to sleep
around yeah while your mother and father
is dying in Care Homes the Sharia
teaches you to go the prophet Muhammad
PE upon him said may his face be robbed
in dust may his face be robbed in dust
may his face be robbed in dust for the
one his parents reach old age and he
doesn't look after them you are starving
for the Shar you are thirsty for the
Shar the Shar is there to look at after
the poor who is sleeping on the streets
freezing to death yes the Shar has come
to protect the right of the woman the
right of the man the Sharia has come to
put all in society get rid of your
diseases of drugs cocaine alcohol um
theft murder everything you are dying
and thirsty for the Sharia yeah we are
proud as Muslims not the Sharia that you
think of going and chopping people up
and stuff like that this watching stor
movie or something like that for that
matter the Shar is there to put
communities and have Justice and be
upholders of Justice that's the reason
why millions of people are flocking to
Islam in the Western
World so all I have to say say is
disguise be proud of your religion be
firm in your religion there is no one
but Allah that's going to be there for
you okay know that very well and strive
for his sake brothers and sisters with
your inner self and then telling people
about Islam sharing the Quran the Quran
is the greatest form of jihad we have
the Quran yes like Allah says in the
Quran fight with them with what the
greater J scholar say is what it's the
Quran we don't need m weapons of mass
destruction we don't need AK-47s or any
weapons for that matter allow us to
teach and preach the Quran that is the
only thing we need and that is the only
thing you thing you fear because when
the Quran is recited when they hear it
people come to Islam flocking people
just look at the resistance people look
at the the the resilience the people in
Palestine have and they are like what
kind of a book is this that makes these
people so so resilient and strong in
their faith it is
Islam read it and share it for yourself
in brother and sisters Piers
Morgan take a good look at this face
you're going to see it one day and it's
not going to be on your
show